las vegas known as the entertainment
capital of the world but of course the
spotlight has mostly dimmed during this
time
creating some issues for many working in
the entertainment industry
eight news now reporter christian
drummond shows us how some continue to
adapt to ensure a return of the arts
local entertainment venues like the
majestic repertory theater here in
downtown las vegas continue to adapt
during the pandemic
despite the struggles it was devastating
at the beginning
it was terrifying troy hurd avoids the
final curtain call at the majestic
we are scraping by fortunately by
donations
and some of the ticket sales when christ
was
born the artistic director creatively
finds new ways to generate some money
and
entertain audiences
we just finished a production last night
that toured people's front yards it was
a caroling family that went out and
spread
cheer joy and a little weirdness
developing productions
outside the typical theater space
that includes a drive-in in the back of
the building car drives right on in
the black curtain closes and you have a
show
with live actors projection stage
lighting
various theater programs in the valley
are trying to adapt
even going online but a lack of revenue
brings some changes
including for broadway in the hood
unfortunately we had to move out of the
space that we were in
because we could not afford the rent the
pandemic emergency technical support
grant or
pets aims to help it provides arts and
culture organizations
some relief to continue operations the
members of the producers alliance so far
have already confirmed three hundred
thousand dollars worth of grants
to local arts and culture organizations
money to sustain
we were blessed to receive a twenty
thousand dollar grant from
the pets the pets grant i see a light at
the end of the tunnel
so the shows go on kristen drummond 8
news now
many also watching what happens with the
save our stages act in congress it may
pass the potential coven 19 relief bill
and if it does
it can provide funding assistance for
local theaters